así que tenemos a los 100 lógicos todos
con sus frentes pintadas de azul y antes
que ellos entren al cuarto se les dice
dos cosas que al menos uno de ellos de
esos 100 lógicos tiene la frente pintada
de azul y que después de prender la luz
y verse los unos a los otros
si ellos concluyen que tienen la frente
pintada de azul tienen que abandonar el
cuarto porque es una de las reglas
entonces cada vez que se apague la luz
van a tener que retirarse las personas
que ya saben que tienen la frente
pintada de azul y así sucesivamente van
a volver a prender la luz se van a
volver a ver todos los que quedan
adentro de la habitación de la frente
azul y los que concluyan que tienen la
frente pintada de azul van a salirse de
la habitación de la frente azul ahora
bien también cabe mencionar que todos
sabían que dando unos lógicos perfectos
entonces la pregunta del problema era
qué pasa si todos los 100 integrantes de
esta habitación del al frente azul
tienen la frente pintada de azul
entonces la pregunta era qué es lo que
va a pasar o una pregunta mejor porque
va a pasar lo que va a pasar y bueno lo
primero que voy a hacer es
la pregunta de qué va a pasar lo que va
a pasar es lo siguiente se va a aprender
y se va a apagar la luz cien veces se va
a prender y se va a apagar la luz
cien veces antes de que todos se vayan
de la habitación es decir cuando se
prende la luz por centésima vez ya no va
a haber nadie en esa habitación y más
aún todos se van a ir al mismo tiempo es
decir en las 99 veces anteriores que se
prende la luz todos van a seguir ahí
todos los lógicos absolutos van a seguir
ahí y cuando apaguen la luz por
centésima vez todos se van a ir al mismo
tiempo de tal manera que cuando se
vuelva a prender la luz ya no va a haber
nadie en la habitación y bueno si tú
escuchas solamente lo que va a pasar sin
entender qué es lo que está pasando
seguramente suena un poco místico
imagínate la escena tú tienes a 99
personas enfrente de ti con todas con la
frente pintada de azul entonces apagan
la luz prende la luz y vuelves a ver
todas las 99 personas y apagan la luz y
prenden la luz y otra vez ves a todas
las 99 personas y apagan la luz y así
sucesivamente hasta que la vez
apagan la luz por centésima vez todos se
van de la habitación y sé que suena un
poco descabellado que las 99 veces
pasadas no pase nada sin embargo vamos a
intentar razonar por qué pasa esta
situación para esto vamos a ver primero
un ejemplo más sencillo en lugar de
tener 100 personas me voy a tomar un
ejemplo más trivial pero eso sí lo que
sí quiero dejar claro es que lo que
sabemos siempre es que al menos una
persona tiene la frente pintada de azul
y tan pronto cuanto ella sepa que tiene
la frente pintada de azul
va a abandonar la habitación en ese
mismo momento y todos son unos lógicos
perfectos así que vamos a ver el caso
más sencillo supongamos que solamente
hay una persona y esa persona está en la
habitación azul y soy yo entonces voy a
entrar a la habitación de la frente azul
y me voy a sentar justo ahí de hecho
creo que debería de hacerlo con azul y
bueno como todas las personas en esta
habitación de la frente azul tienen la
frente pintada de azul pues yo tengo la
frente pintada de azul
muerto a mi alrededor y no veo a nadie
más recuerden que yo no sé si tengo la
frente pintada de azul o no pero lo que
sí sé son las instrucciones que me
dieron
si hacemos un poco de memoria y las
tenemos bastante presentes
voy a recordar que la primera dice al
menos una persona tiene la frente
pintada de azul
al menos una persona tiene la frente
pintada de azul por lo tanto yo he
vuelto a mi alrededor veo que me
encuentro solo y pienso al menos uno de
nosotros tiene la frente pintada de azul
como soy el único no me queda más que
selección el que tengo la frente pintada
de azul entonces cuando apaga la luz me
voy del lugar ok
este es el caso muy sencillo y
seguramente ustedes se van a preguntar
bueno y qué tiene que ver esto con tener
cien personas metidas en el cuarto de la
frente azul entonces vamos a complicar
un poco más y ahora me voy a tomar a dos
personas
voy a suponer que está esta persona y
van a ser dibujo tras dibujo voy a poner
en esta misma habitación de la frente
azul a mi segundo participante y
recuerden que estamos en el caso
hipotético en donde a todas las personas
que entren a la habitación de la frente
azul les pinto la frente de color azul y
bueno para resolver este segundo caso me
voy a meter en la mente de este
personaje que estoy seleccionando y
bueno vamos a intentar ponernos en sus
zapatos y pensar como él si yo fuera él
tendría dos posibilidades
o la frente pintada de azul o no tengo
la frente pintada de azul
entonces voy a escribir lo hola tengo
azul o no la tengo azul o no la tengo
azul recuerden que yo al ingresar a la
habitación de la frente azul no sé de
qué color tengo mi frente entonces
supongamos que yo soy este tipo y tengo
la frente pintada de azul porque
nosotros sabemos que estamos usando la
hipótesis de que todos tienen la frente
pintada de azul entonces qué pasa
supongamos que prendes la luz y yo veo a
la persona que está enfrente de mí si yo
veo a la persona que está enfrente de mí
veo que él tiene la frente pintada de
azul ahora bien recuerdan que yo no sé
si tengo la frente pintada de azul o no
entonces vamos a ver el primer caso
vamos a irnos al mundo irreal de que no
tuviera la frente pintada de azul como
tendría que pensar en ese momento bueno
si no tuvieras la frente pintada de azul
entonces yo veo que la persona de
adelante si tiene la frente pintada de
azul por lo tanto cuando apaguen la luz
es se va a tener que ir de la habitación
porque pues su lógica va a ser la
siguiente
a ver a mí que no tengo la frente
pintada de azul porque recuerden que
estamos en el caso hipotético de que no
tengo la frente pintada de azul es más
hasta luego ya en marcar no tengo la
frente pintada de azul estoy en este
caso hipotético entonces como me ve a mí
que yo no tengo la frente pintada en
azul es va a recordar las reglas del
juego y la regla primera de este juego
dice al menos uno de los participantes
que están en la habitación de la frente
azul debe de tener la frente pintada de
azul por lo tanto él descubre que él es
el que tiene en la frente pinta de azul
y siguiendo la segunda regla del juego
va a tener que abandonar la habitación
justo cuando se apague la luz
bueno bueno pero eso era en el caso
hipotético de que no tuviera la cabeza
pintada de azul como ambos tenemos la
cabeza pintada de azul que es lo que va
a pasar lo que va a pasar es lo
siguiente van a pagar la luz van a
prender la luz y el cuarto de enfrente
va a seguir ahí y yo que tengo en la
cabeza pintada de azul me voy a dar
cuenta que el cuate que estaba enfrente
va a seguir ahí porque es va a seguir
una lógica parecida a la mía va a pensar
la persona de enfrente tiene la frente
pintada de azul por lo tanto yo no me
salgo
eso quiere decir que yo si tengo la
frente pintada de azul en este caso
cuando vuelvan a apagar la luz por
segunda vez yo ya sé que tengo la frente
pintada de azul por lo tanto me tengo
que retirar y él también sabe que tiene
la frente pintada de asus por lo tanto
también se va a retirar de la habitación
de la frente azul cuando apaguen la luz
por segunda vez y cuando prendan la luz
por segunda vez ya no va a haber nadie
en la habitación
voy a intentar repetirlo para entender
bien qué fue lo que pasó hace que pongan
mucha atención si por primera vez apagan
la luz y una persona de las que están
adentro de la habitación de la frente
azul se retira eso quiere decir que la
otra persona no tenía la frente pintada
de azul ahora bien qué es lo que pasa si
se prende la luz por segunda vez y se
encuentran ahí en la misma habitación
cada uno de los dos personajes bueno en
ese momento los dos concluyen que tienen
la frente pintada de azul y deciden irse
de la habitación frente azul bueno ahora
para seguir aumentando el número de
personas voy a ver el caso donde son
tres personas pero antes de eso quiero
analizar una cosa cuando había solamente
una persona de se cuenta que esa persona
se salió en la primera
es que apagaron la luz ahora bien cuando
había dos personas en la habitación
frente azul en la segunda vez que
apagaban la luz se retiraron ambos al
darse cuenta que las dos personas tenían
la frente pintada de azul qué va a pasar
ahora en el caso de que son tres
personas creo que ya están observando
qué es lo que va a pasar y qué patrón
cumplen entonces tomemos a una dos tres
personas y bueno ahora me voy a meter en
la mente de este chico que tengo aquí me
voy a meter en la mente de este gran
lógico que yo tengo aquí y tengo a
través dos opciones o mi frente está
azul o mi frente no está azul no está
azul muy bien entonces vamos a irnos al
mundo hipotético otra vez donde no
tenemos la frente pintada azul si no
tuviera la frente pintada azul qué pasa
con el tipo que está en mi derecha bueno
él me ve a mí que no tengo la frente
pintada de azul ve a la persona de
enfrente que si tiene la frente pintada
de azul y entonces entra en confusión
pero supongamos que esta persona que
está a la derecha tampoco tuviera la
frente pintada de azul si yo no tengo la
frente pintada de azul y la persona de
mi derecha tampoco tiene la frente
azul entonces la persona que está arriba
ve a dos personas que no tienen la
frente en pintada azul y por lo tanto él
se da cuenta que él es el único que
tiene la frente pintada de azul y decide
retirarse del cuarto ahora bien qué pasa
si por segunda vez se prende la luz y la
persona que está arriba no se ha ido del
cuarto pues bueno entonces la persona de
la derecha va a decir la persona de
arriba tiene la frente azul y se dio
cuenta de que hay alguien más del cuarto
que tiene la frente azul por lo tanto no
se salió del cuarto y si la persona de
mi izquierda no tiene la frente azul
pues por lo tanto yo soy el que tengo la
frente azul y los dos vamos a abandonar
la habitación cuando se apague la luz
por segunda vez recuerden que estamos en
el caso hipotético de que la primera
persona la persona de la izquierda no
tiene la frente azul ahora qué pasa en
el caso real en donde los tres tienen la
frente azul bueno se prende la luz una
vez se apaga la luz se prende la luz una
vez se apaga la luz y en la tercera vez
se encuentran otra vez los tres tipos en
la habitación en ese momento se dan
cuenta los tres que tienen en la frente
azul
por lo tanto deciden salir los tres al
mismo tiempo de la habitación cuando se
apague la luz por tercera vez recuerden
que son lógicos perfectos y eso lo
concluyen la tercera vez que se apaga la
luz y salen todos al mismo tiempo hasta
podrían chocar cuando salgan ahora qué
pasa si perdemos a un cuarto integrante
pues va a pasar lo mismo que con tres
integrantes si no tienen la frente azul
es se va a dar cuenta que después de
tres veces que se prendan se apagan la
luz van a salir de la habitación las
tres personas que tienen la frente
pintada de azul ahora sí después de la
cuarta vez que se prende la luz siguen
ahí las otras tres personas no queda de
otra la cuarta persona también tiene la
frente pintada de azul y todos van a
salir al mismo tiempo cuando se apague
la luz por cuarta vez y lo mismo pasaría
en el caso de tuvieras cinco personas 20
personas siempre son las millones de
personas por la cantidad de personas que
ustedes quieran al final ahora
entendemos el patrón que cumple este
acertijo y en qué momento van a
abandonar todas las personas la
habitación pero bueno hemos llegado a la
solución de este acertijo que parecía
sobrenatural y ahora se me ha acabado el
tiempo así que mejor nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo